breaking tonight a drastic and desperate
deterioration of the situation in
afghanistan
seven thousand one hundred and eighty
nine days after u.s and afghan forces
took back control of the southern city
of kandahar from the taliban taliban
fighters have now taken control again of
the second largest city in the country
according to authorities on the ground
and today 19 years eight months and six
days later afghan officials and u.s
military leaders are concerned the
capital city of kabul could be next as
the u.s continues its official troop
withdrawal
tonight the pentagon is sending back in
3 000 additional forces and even more to
evacuate americans as the taliban close
in on kabul two other major afghan
cities herat and ghazni quickly fell to
the taliban today
lucas tomlinson is at the pentagon with
the latest good evening lucas good
evening brett three infantry battalions
some three thousand soldiers marines and
all we deploying to kabul the next two
days after warnings the afghan capital
could fall to the taliban in the next 90
days here's how pentagon press secretary
john kirby described the mission
this is a temporary mission with a
narrow focus as with all deployments of
our troops into harm's way our
commanders have the inherent right of
self-defense and any attack on them can
and will be met with a forceful and an
appropriate response
eight thousand u s troops be deployed
not only to afghanistan but to the
middle east as well in addition to the 3
000 soldiers and marines going to kabul
4 000 soldiers from the alert brigade at
fort bragg will be deploying to kuwait
to be held in reserve in case they're
needed in afghanistan they arrive next
week a thousand additional soldiers will
be deploying to qatar and to help
accommodate thousands of afghan
interpreters who help the u.s military
as long as they're with their families
refugees fleeing the war-torn country
this comes as the taliban has been on a
lightning offensive in the past week ten
days ago the taliban controlled zero
provincial capitals tonight they control
12. the latest kandahar city the second
largest city in afghanistan and the
spiritual home of the taliban fell
earlier today the state department today
also ordering thousands of americans out
of the country the embassy will remain
open for now with essential personnel
only the pentagon is not calling this
additional deployment of troops a combat
deployment
you're telling me that the marines and
the soldiers are about to strap it on
going to kabul this is in combat lucas
what i'm telling you is and i've said it
before they will have the ability to
defend themselves they will be armed of
course they're going for a security
mission
when i asked kirby if the u.s military
would be fully withdrawn from the
country by the end of august he said
that timeline remains intact brett
lucas thomason at the pentagon lucas
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else